no I'm ready faces up welcome back to
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another episode of special one I finally
got somebody on the show who I've been
trying to get on the show
for a very very long time this is my
white whale you know this finally got
him on took a world pandemic to get this
dude on this show but Terry is from
Modern Family righteous dead stop the
movie sexy and workaholics
[Music]
[Music]
ah man stupid anyways ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the program mr.
Adam Devine I before I even bring them
on before I have them you know to play
the recording because it's pre-recorded
but this is actually recorded too but
whatever you got I'll need the inside
information but anyways I really
appreciate you guys listening and
supporting the show subscribing and all
that stuff if you want to see me game I
asked a game on Eric Griffin gaming on
twitch and YouTube same name Eric
Griffin gaming so please check me out on
there if you want to see that but this
guy come on show Adam Devine I just you
know very special to me the relationship
that I have with him and the other guys
from workaholics Blake and onder's
Jillian Marybeth Kyle all the people
from the show it was the first big thing
I did it was such an honor to be a part
of such an iconic show so many people
still watch it today people still call
me Montez you know it's just I don't
know it's one of those special things
that you get to be a part of and I will
always treasure it so I really
appreciate him coming on the show
My partner Klein would prompt crime with
the Clippers you know we love the
Clippers of course look what happened so
it's like we talked about that we talked
about a lot of great stuff but curious
right now please enjoy mr. Adam Devine
all right so after popular demand after
begging here we is everybody mr. Adam
Devine hello hey what's up what's up to
your dozen fans yeah thank you all all
eleven it's crazy because your mom's one
of my fans your mom is a big supporter I
love your mom your mom's one of my
favorite Hollywood moms you know oh
she's a Hollywood mom well yeah because
you're a big Hollywood star so she would
be a Hollywood model you know as she
plays the part well you know and this is
why I came on the on the podcast so I
could get some through some great
affirmations I can feel good about
myself you called me a big Hollywood
star big love you hear that she's a
Hollywood
- oh man she's like oh and she loves
defending you man she gets into more
twitter or like or like facebook battles
with people that anybody I've ever seen
well she's not defending me she's like
screaming at people about how much he
hates Trump she's not she often gets in
who's hating on me well before I used to
see like if somebody would say something
that she'd be right there being like I
gotta ask the dumb obligatory question
of you know well actually it looks like
you're doing well during this quarantine
then coronavirus situation yes I will
say you throw the best parties at that
place where were you out yeah we won't
give the address or anything but yeah
[Laughter]
that's cool I always say like the the
sign that you're a really good dude is
that is your party's and the people that
come and the vibe and things that they
say you know what I mean so you do that
this is a nice people only type of party
at your party keep the dicks and the
coke heads that they need them there
yeah so like what what is happening man
I've seen you're still trying to do
stuff I saw you go first take that's my
fate one of my favorite shows i watch it
daily starting our first take and I was
like ah I wish I was funnier man it's so
hard when they're like it's it's like
you're living a quarantine lifestyle
we're comics so we're used to getting up
late anyways and then now it's just been
like I'm noon I'm a noon
wake up er and so they were like hey 7
a.m. be on first take Stephen H Smith is
gonna be staring you down Max Kellerman
is hitting you with the one-two punch
and I'm like
goobers trying to be charming and funny
and you're always charming and funny yes
it's sad for us because I feel like the
one time that our Clippers are like at
the precipice at the gates of glory like
the favourites to win and what is the
most slippery thing ever it's the most
glittering most it couldn't have been
more yeah I mean it's exactly what would
happen to us as clipper fans of course
this would happen I know I just it's
just like I don't even know what to even
say about it well you know what you can
be more sweet when we do win I know but
that's it and and why it's not gonna go
anywhere and Paul George isn't gonna go
anywhere if they took this season from
us they have to stick around you know
they have to to see what would actually
happen if we got in the playoffs so but
do they I mean the economics of the NBA
is gonna change like if the they they're
gonna finish the season they're just not
going to be in front of fans I mean I
don't see us going back to the stadium
for a while
excuse me for a while but you you know
it's like you think about um I heard a
rumor that they wanted to go to Las
Vegas and like take over hotels you know
and like do it like that and like I'd
watch I mean I'm dying for it I mean
you'd watch right like no matter what
they show
yeah for sure I like that you hear in a
rumor it's like we have some like inside
skin of those shows I heard it on two
shows actually but it's still a rumor
because it happened that's true doesn't
mean it's gonna you got your ear to the
street Eric I know my ear it's my ear to
the the every morning I was quarantined
living for you you got that green screen
so that's yeah pretty of video games and
stuff like that cuz the reason why I
have the grease keys gum I'm actually
gonna be sitting on your shoulder right
now as we're as we're doing this I'm
gonna be on like on your left side right
there it's gonna look great
nice I'm doing my thing you know I mean
I got Rachel's with me you know what I
mean so you know
that's that's that was challenging at
first you know I mean yeah I'm sure any
relationship because you're like you're
living you you you would never live like
this in my situation everybody just
immediately became an old retired
married couple then they'd already went
through all the spells of like I hate
you I love you yeah like thirty years of
relationship under our belt but instead
we just have a couple years or less than
that and we're thrown into retirement
life I know it's it's crazy I was
telling her like I feel like I've spent
more I think that we've actually spent
more physical time together in this past
month then like Oh like the last three
years I just you know total like it's
like 24 hours a day you still you start
to think about like damn I spend a lot
of time with this person it's like
accelerated accelerated relationship but
you don't like that
how you do like because you're engaged
like it's actually awesome
oh yeah we're loving it but I feel like
after this quarantine people are either
going to be like you know what she is
the one or they're gonna be like yeah
and we pretend we're you are breaking up
as soon as this is over with day one out
of quarantine we can't break up during
quarantine because we're stuck with each
other but there's no there's no going to
be like yeah we'll see how it goes it's
like hey it's been decided dude I know
what you mean I read an article about it
in China that it was like divorces are
up like five five times it's just like
people came out of their quarantine like
yeah it's this ain't gonna work
you know I saw the I saw this movie on a
plane and I just watched it the other
day with my girl that isn't it romantic
yeah and I was like this is such a sweet
movie but I gotta ask you though at the
end of the movie there's this big dance
sequence and it looked like a horrific
day of shoe that bad if you you probably
notice only notice because it's me it's
my face in my body so you end up just
kind of you know it is when you watch
yourself on a screen you like aren't
watching objectively you're just like
staring at your dumb face going like I
wish I wouldn't yeah I wish I would have
those like eight pieces of pizza the
night before my head looks atrocious but
I was we shot that that was like a
pickup after the fact like the whole
movie was done in the can edited and
then they did some testing and they were
like yeah we won't take a big fun like
that what was testing the highest was
the song and dance number in the bar
love the karaoke scene and and then they
were like yeah we want more of that
especially from like me and rebel like
doing the pitch perfect movies together
they wanted us singing and dancing more
so they like designed this whole song
and dance number but I was shooting the
righteous gemstones at the same at the
same time so I had already got my big
dumb righteous gemstones haircut well I
have my hair and like the coins and
they're like you can't cut it we were
like in between scenes like I glued in
New York from South Carolina for like
four days to shoot that and then flew
back to continue with righteous gemstone
so like you can't cut your hair so I
have this big dumb hair that kept like
flopping around while shooting that
dance sequence in the whole time I'm
like it's not gonna cut together the
whole movie is ruined and meanwhile
everyone's like no one gives a [ __ ]
about your hair they're looking at
Priyanka Chopra they're laughing at
rubble you're just in the movie be happy
be happy you're just in the movie it was
actually a sweet movie yeah you are you
know you do that great like earrings man
movie I've seen you in where like you're
just
because for some reason you're always
that guy who wins in the end but he
wasn't winning the whole movie and then
finally people realize he's not handsome
well I mean it's hard having Hemsworth
there like that [ __ ] is so
handsome for no reason at all it's just
he's disgustingly handsome so I get it
when you're next to him you're like okay
he's the leading man but talented it's
kind of off-putting Jesus man
cuz he's so funny he's funny in that
movie too what he's like yeah he's just
a [ __ ] stud and you're like yeah hey
I get it
I get why Hollywood as pigeon-holed me
in this role and you're pigeon-holed as
a super leading man I get that nice to
be pigeonholed in that but you know it's
like you know we go way back you know
the whole the workaholics days you know
I know you hate it but I always like
everybody always ask me about
workaholics and I always tell the same
story about how I didn't know that it
was your show like I had yeah no I had
no idea that you were because we just
saw each other and I I saw you at that
Brea improv I'll never forget it and
you're just like going up doing your set
and I was like you know what kid you're
doing good which is nice because you
were like the more veteran comic and I'm
like a younger comic you know is like
what probably twenty four or five and
and you were like hey you know what I
even in my mind when I saw you in the
room I thought to myself oh this guy's
really getting around look at him
interning at the
I didn't know at the time history I
totally could have been an intern on
that like the acceleration that we had
from like making YouTube videos and me
going and doing little spots not even
headlining The Improv sore anything like
just being a feature act to go from that
to like having it my own show was like
such a zero to 100 real quick and then
it went to zero to like a million like
you know what when the thing came out I
mean I mean honestly I remember reading
the audition and I had two thoughts
about it the first thought was like
they're never gonna let me say this
stuff on television it was so crazy too
because the first audition I remember
doing it like I remember working on it
because it was so crazy and I thought if
I could do this on TV that'll be so
funny you know so I said let me go all
balls out on this like you know and then
I remember like the casting directors
after I did my audition they stopped
they looked at each other and they went
okay this might be a take you know and
then I remember and then I remember
coming into the the first that first
time I saw you there and I'm looking in
this room of people and I'm like I'm
never gonna get this there's the guy
from Boston Legal there's the guy from
the George Lopez show there's Jay
Phillips
there's the dude from this other thing
and I was like what am i doing in here
you know what I mean
and then it's just like but I always use
that as a story to tell people never
think you can't get something you just
go out and you know do it dude give it
your all
you know what I mean yeah you never know
like what people are looking for like we
didn't really want since we were like
super young and didn't have a lot of
experience but wanted you know we're the
bosses and we want people to listen to
us we didn't want someone that like had
was super famous and had been on a ton
of other stuff that would come in and be
like no we're doing it my way because
I've done XYZ focus away from you yeah
we're like no we want to do it this way
because we don't want it to feel like
whatever else Boston Legal
like exactly like Boston Legal yeah man
I I yeah it was like it was probably one
of the most gratifying experiences is
just being a part of workaholics and
seeing it all like you know I often say
though that people should watch it in
Reverse you know that's I think just
getting younger yeah watch you guys get
younger because I just think that the
purest time of the show is like in the
first two couple of seasons like my
favorite episodes day is the office
campout you know I think that's my
favorite episode because it just it
capsule eights what you guys are and
you're in your wheel sort of like real
fake French you know me like the fake in
know Hollywood but like in the on the TV
but it has some of like how you guys
really are with each other and I just
thought that that was you know anyway it
just it was just it was just a really
great experience you know and then but
when you came off of that go you know I
agree I think I think it's not that
there's not awesome episodes in the
later seasons of the show but it's it's
like any show it's like you come out the
gate knowing exactly what the show is
and then it and then the show kind of
morphs and changes and then you feel
like you can't do certain episodes
certain ways because it would be too
similar to an episode you've done before
and then you're trying not to copy
yourself and then you start to get away
from what you did with the show
initially that you know what I mean I
think that's it's a common common thing
with any show that goes for seven
seasons I feel yeah you guys learned how
to write direct produce you know
beatbeat actors on the show that I mean
it was just like amazing thing to watch
like like I always one of my favorite
and worst days of the show would be like
when ders was directing I always knew it
was director during I was codirector
ders is here cuz he's like I don't know
why he just turned it to a different
person and I never understood it I asked
him about it he's been on my podcast
already actually actually almost
everyone has been on the part
except you this is your and now I'm on
actually Blake was my first guess but I
asked ders about it what's up with you a
director ders days he just would like
flip into like a different different
person to be like okay but then like I
remember when you directed it was still
like you never really changed you know
you just was like you know you kind of
kept that same energy so it's just like
it's just so weird that he would like
compartmentalizes so well in his head so
like he just like shifts over to like
this is my director mode yeah yeah and
then it's like it's a little bit more
dickish than it should be this is way I
know what am i yeah he was always the
grown-up of the group you know I know
one of my favorite days one of the the
because they were sweet you know seven
years is so many days right but this is
one of my favorite favorite ever days of
workaholics is when we're doing that
that's seance and we were it was like
what a random take we're just you know I
didn't I didn't know they said action
and you and Jillian were just cracking
me I thought we were rehearsing and I
just was laughing the whole take because
like you just were doing this stuff and
I was just like my god this is like like
how am I not laughing all the time with
these people in the net then it was like
cut and you were like oh my god good
times man I don't know when you came
home it was the best man I do I miss it
a lot sometimes simplicity well it was
so fun and it was like we were so like
new to everything so everything was
still so excited you know like the fact
that we were all getting paid and we
were doing it and we were making a show
together and it felt like we were like
the little show that could and then did
it felt it felt it was so fun and
everyone always said like this is gonna
be it won't get better than this just so
you know
like tons of people tell me that like
more establish people that they're like
like you will go and you'll probably
make more money doing other things and
you know you you might get more famous
doing other things or whatever but it
won't get better than this and I was
like it's just gonna be better it's
totally true in other movies and you
know and other shows or whatever but
it's like doing that show was that was
the best yeah I guess it was different
for me because it was like I didn't this
is a strange but for me it was like ah
like that was how because it was like
low-budget at first you know what I mean
like we were like you know we took over
you guys took over an office building
and turned this office building into
like the said and then our red dressing
rooms were offices and it was just like
just like a weird like processor cue
till the show got bigger so like you
know you think that's how it is for like
when you're a supporting cast member and
then you go on other shows and stuff
you're like I know like I told like
Chloe was just amazed when she found out
that Nene Blake Kyle and ders shared the
same trailer for seven seasons
which is like people don't know like you
know people that are listening this one
of the eleven people that are listening
this that mom already knows like like as
an actor when you get your own like
little trailer or you at least like your
own little room and then and then as the
show gets bigger everybody kind of gets
their own trailer and it becomes a
bigger thing but we were so like
low-budget and kept them so like in
house that we just shared the same
trailer and we as producers we were like
it'll save us money and we could put
that money towards the show as opposed
to us being fancy and just having her
own trailer yeah that's yeah that's that
was pretty amazing I look at I think
back on that it was like
cuz you know key I mean it was big you
know the show got big I mean it was huge
it was like and the thing about it too
was like it was like people's favorite
show like to this day it's people's
favorite show
like there's a lot of shows on the air
there's a lot of shows that come and go
but there's not that many few shows that
touch people the way workaholics did
well you know what's weird is when you
meet someone now it just makes you feel
[ __ ] old dude when I meet somebody in
there they're 40 like they they're like
they might be like like I'm 36 years old
now but then they might be like 32 or
something or in there or like 30 and and
be like I grew up with your show yeah
and then have like a beard and they're
balding and you're like it's pretty it's
pretty amazing and then for me it was
like see lucky for you guys you're Adam
so it's like Adam Adam you know so you
walk down a street people go Adam you
know for me it's like you know Montez
you know like just air all the time and
so I don't care like I I I'm not like
what's-his-name from super bad you know
he didn't want to make a big love in oh
yeah yeah he just he hates that from
what I hear you know he's like you know
so I I always knew it was like once that
started to happen I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna be this is who I'm gonna be
forever as long as people watch this
show
but luckily because of social media to
find me you have to find out my name is
Erik Griffin so they go with my social
media it like even confuses people more
because I have a fake name as my
Instagram so people think people like
what's Adam demands real name and then
they look me up on Instagram and they're
like it's Andy Bova fake name that I
made when I thought I put in when I was
because I didn't know Instagram was
gonna be such a big deal I thought it's
gonna be like a fun thing to share
photos with friends and you never got a
chance to change it to Andy Devon yeah
Adam Devine you never want you don't
even know my real name [ __ ] Andy
Devon Charlie Smith everyone not me you
never wanted to change it to your real
name or you tried or somebody already
has it no my publicist was like you can
they were like we could get it for you
and I was like [ __ ] it kind of funny
it's not funny not to I think when you
care too much that's that's when it's
off-putting to people yeah it's just
Andy move on it's fine when you are
finished workaholics and you you were
moving on to other things cuz you
already you know did was there was there
a time and even now do you feel like
you're still there's like 70% of it is
you're still typecast as adam demamp you
know me that's the second part of that
question or but not that that's a bad
thing because it is a part of your
comedic character that you bring to a
lot of your performances but there a
part of you that's like I kind of want
to like be like you know in the in the
in irishman no I mean I feel like I kind
of got lucky with doing Modern Family at
the same time I was doing work with
workaholics and so that character was
such a sweetheart it was like such like
a kind of a pure nice guy and not that
demand wasn't him nice guy but he was
just a [ __ ] maniac he was like a wild
man so I got to play the wild man and
then I gotta go over to Fox and play
like this over the model family would
shot at the Fox Studios and got to play
like the sweetheart of a guy and I think
that helped may not get totally tight
guys that's why I think I'm doing a lot
of these romantic comedies and stuff now
because people have seen me do that in
in other shows
you know like my family I don't think
it's kind of amazing how you're known
for so many different things by so many
different people like we would go to the
Clipper games together
it would be funny like how like a
middle-aged woman would come up and be
like oh my god it's like what was it
wasn't the character's name Andy on the
yeah
oh it's Andy from Modern Family and then
like some kids will be like you know you
know it's like it's like a pitch-perfect
so it was like it was like actually uh
like a plethora of like a store a
perfect storm of like different types of
things you know yeah yeah I'm just doing
a podcast now so my actually I'm talking
with the guys right now about maybe
doing a podcast together oh here we go
here it is look at this what do you
think I'm talking to you finally I know
now I could get him on when he's like
not like so many of my friends had
podcast and I do want to be a good
friend and do podcasts and talk with you
guys but everybody was asking me right
when I came off of all the press from
jexy and that movie I did so much god
damn press I did every talk show you can
do I did The Tonight Show I did Colbert
I did Kim all I did Ellen I did Kelly
Carson you know the Today Show like I
was [ __ ] everywhere and I was just so
sick of seeing myself and talking you
know talking about especially talking
about like this same project over and
over and over again you know yeah and
then that project just kind of didn't do
that well in the theaters and I was just
kind of like I'm [ __ ] done talking
with people for Ferb how are you uh how
is it being engaged like I was it like
you know you're you're a grown-ass man
now dude you don't do it
as long as you can
violin I always remember though like
looking back at when you guys were
you're in your early twenties you're on
this show that is catering to
college-age kids and it's just you know
you know you had you had your time to be
like a you know a sex symbol huh true
sexy yeah I think it was good it was
important to like have a few years well
you know were you like doing dumb dumb
Hollywood stuff like you going to the
club which I've never did like when I
was 21 two years old like I couldn't
afford to go even to a bar I would like
to smell in my own alcohol two bars
because I couldn't afford alcohol so
like when when the show finally became
popular when I was like 25 years old 26
years old when this show finally hit
yeah I definitely took a little bit of
time a couple years to like yeah yeah
some say but now look another 36 Jesus
like you know you're practically 40 baby
you're over 35 now so now you're grown
up which is like I think that's when men
grow up and now you're like about yeah
yeah it's all right 36 years old how old
were you when you started work hauling
40 45 46 you piece of [ __ ] I don't even
know I don't remember I was in my late
30s late 30s yes so you have always been
the oldest person I've ever known yeah
you know it's this like weird thing that
like I have I could have another memory
from workaholics that I want to say it
was like that future future is NAR you
know uh-huh
we're sitting here on set I had this too
banes [ __ ] on and a balding cap and you
know I was such an insane episode
they're doing we're doing a stunt where
you barrel around a corner and kick and
[ __ ] tackle me in the chest you know
and then the stunt guy this was the
stunt talk just saw you know breathe out
Eric breathe out and I'm like what
action then here you come with all the
bits of energy of whatever Tori to my
chest into a bow that was too real no
it's nothing you do anything to me I'm
just an athlete oh yeah yeah that's why
you almost broke your body playing bat
spilling fake basketball I know I tore
my ACL doing a episode of workaholics I
was the worst yeah those are worse but
you know so you guys scrambled you got
that together you just change the story
right in the middle of it but I remember
when that happened we hear you screaming
outside and then everybody looked at
each other like yes speaking of not on
the script it's just some of the
people's favorite moments and they say
these lines back to me are these things
that weren't in the script Adam like oh
your knuckles are hairy wildly your
big-ass nose that was that one dude
that's improv geniuses you know we take
this and we use it you know I had this I
talk about this in my am I one of my
specials I said you know it's like when
you're playing a character that's just
crazy you're playing to care you're not
crazy you know when you're playing a
character who's like whatever like you
know they're a senator you're not a
senator but
like you're playing a fat character if
it says so when you look at the
character and say hey you fat [ __ ] yeah
but that's not mine
that's because I would never do that I'm
not a mean person but the man in the
office and they go toe to toe they go
head to head
oh yeah they go head to head yeah I
always remember my first my first ever
seen in workaholics my first ever lines
and workaholics
I know it too is just because always I
remember that cuz I was my first big
thing you know it was like I guess my
invitation got lost in the mail that was
my first ever line and you did this for
like a solid season and a half where you
were so bad at hitting your mark in look
down on the ground just like you you
were you were no you weren't a pro right
away I remember we did that episode
where Kyle was hitting me with that
double-headed I was hitting it with that
two-headed dildo you know and he you
know and so when he's acting in a scene
so you know and then cuz he would always
get on me by hitting my mark you know
Eric that's your job hitting your mark
and then like he didn't hit his mark and
I was like yeah yeah Kyle was like you
know with Costco to recall him dirty
brown water troughs in the show he'd
played call of the drug dealer and you
know we always talk about how smelly and
gross and his character is and then
compile the
santal new check doesn't take offense to
that even though call no check is I love
that guy though cuz he put me in his
movie he put me in a murder mystery so
it's like from the workaholics family
yeah I know that was cool seeing you in
that there was a lot there's a lot of
workaholics people that the tree from
workaholics you know I've been on many
shows and sets where somebody comes up
to me goes hey I was a writer on
workaholics season two and I'm like oh I
never saw you we never saw the writers
just occasionally even when we were
shooting it wasn't like only a couple of
people Scotty or somebody but most of
all it's because we were all so they
didn't have to be there because we were
there you know what I mean like we were
also the writers so we were in the room
all the time so if you had a writer
question we could answer it I read this
a funny funny moment for me for with
Kyle because he he hits me up after I'm
dying up here you know but he goes like
this he says because I talked about I
won him when he was on the podcast too
he says hey man you really grown as a
performer and in my mind I'm like we
were shooting these shows at the same
time like yeah I didn't go away for ten
years and come back like no I just
wasn't used do those type of scenes on
workaholics anyways you know what I mean
it was a fun sitcom
but also was like by my joke with Bill
bill and I you so we have this joke like
when we're doing if it was Bill and I
doing scenes with you guys we would
always have this joke could be like
alright what's the over-under on our
takes on our coverage you know so it'd
be like two like two and a half of me
the number like you know that would be
like two and a half so three we went to
two is a push you know cuz it'll be like
so there's cameras on you guys would be
like okay single on Adam single on Blake
single on ders
double on a demanders triple on adam's
person bleh
okay the zoom in on Adams ooh it'll be
like 15 til you guys got it like
whatever then it's like turn around on
Montez was different when I went on
another show where I was like cuz I cuz
I'd be like you know I do one thing I'd
be like okay well I guess are we done
like no Eric let's get another like it
was a different show I'm dying up here
because it was more of a big ensemble in
workaholics was less of a big ensemble
show and it was the three main guys it
was your guys's show it was our show and
then and then there would be you know
you guys would facilitate the story yeah
I remember season one I used to tweet
out cuz like there'd be like I was in
four episodes season 1 but the camera
would pan by where Montez are supposed
to be sitting uh-huh so that would be
good times though what do you got coming
out besides Rochester um which is
hilarious by the way I really like that
[ __ ] thanks man yeah thanks nothing
right now nothing's in the can another
season of green eggs and ham which I'm
the voice of Oh me and Michael Douglas
and Diane Keaton Jillian's in it too I
play Sam I am
it's on Netflix for a kids kids show
it's awesome it's really fun
yeah and so that'll be coming out later
this year and then and then nothing
we're about to start shooting season two
of righteous gemstone
and look how they caught us cuz I co fit
so we're kind of waiting to go back I
wonder how they're gonna do that - is it
gonna be like even on shows do you think
they're gonna do you think you're gonna
be like like social distancing on the
shows or do you think some shows will
take on start riding like this shows
it's happening during the show or like
how do you think people how do you think
the Hollywood's gonna handle that I I
don't think you can go back to work
under the social distancing guidelines I
think it's gonna be impossible it'd be
impossible because you know the crews
are large unlike a real show on a big
show
there's like over 100 people working and
and you have to end it and they're all
like union shows so you can't just cut
people no you know what I mean it's not
like you could go bare-bones because
then the union will go well no you have
to pay the you know there has to be like
a Transpo team and there has to be like
10 guys on that crew and then the whole
Griffin apartment yeah there has to be
like one person can't do 3 people's jobs
everybody needs to have their job that
they do which is good you know that's
how it should be but during this time
I'm like I don't know how how it's gonna
get done yeah I know what you mean I
even even going back to our previous
discussion about the NBA I don't even
know how they're gonna do that really
you know you cuz you're talking about 14
players the assistant coaches whatever
the crew that's gonna be doing the
broadcasting and and there's got to be
people in the and the in there that's
part of like making it happen I mean how
are any of these kind of entertainment
things especially football like I just
don't see football coming back I know
you're a football guy too especially
college football right yeah and I don't
know how they're gonna do football
school yeah I don't know how I don't
know there's no idea it fell it's gonna
come back and they can't come back
because you're talking about 53-man
roster on either side that's 106 right
there then you're talking about all the
people on the sideline that coaches and
Walter you know how the NFL is like
small compared to college football
football
I mean how many teams are in the yeah
overall you know thirty hundred there's
one hundreds and hundreds yeah of teams
so it's like I have no idea how they're
gonna do that we just we push pause on
2020 we pick it all up at 2021 and we're
right back at it one year older I feel
like I know this is like it's easy for
us to talk about this especially you you
know you're you're sitting on a
beautiful place you know but it's easy
for us and we're not being insensitive
to the people out there that it's like a
different struggle but there are some
like the silver lining to a lot of this
is I think it's good for the environment
I think it's like good for us to like
everybody to like take a beat and slow
down we just need more people to help
other people out you know and hopefully
this won't last for too long where it's
just gonna [ __ ] people which has
probably already has for some people but
for like you know there you gotta find a
way to look at some of the silver lining
cuz it could just be depressing you know
cuz all of us even on every level cuz
look at you you were about to go into
season two that's your career that's
your job that's what you do and it just
stopped at me is so on all different
levels it's the same thing and then for
me like doing stand-up was my main
source of income and now I'm just one so
it's kind of its kind of weird knowing
like people are just sitting in their
houses in Germany you know what I mean
like it's not just Cerritos you know
it's like when a disaster strikes
America and there's a earthquake in LA
it's for instance and LA is dealing with
it who's a bad earthquake and we all are
like oh my god how are we gonna rebuild
the blah blah blah and then the rest of
the world is going oh yeah that happened
in LA cool
that sucks and then they go about their
lives but this is a worldwide pandemic
we're all dealing with it and so when
people are like Oh
the economy the economy it's like yeah
but it's sex to everybody yeah it sucks
for everybody so we're all gonna well
you know I'm not a social scientist so I
don't know really understand all the
repercussions but I think if you know
you kind of wait it out for as long as
you can and hopefully we can get the
antidote and cure this goddamn thing
because it does [ __ ] suck I think
everybody's ready to get back to work
yeah just even how about just spend time
with people I think we're just ready my
dad like see my mom I can't even go see
my mom because you know my mom's got
dementia and I just don't want to go
over there I don't even want to like
even though I haven't gone even cuz I
went to the supermarket so I even feel
like no I don't want to risk it my
parents are over 70 you know you don't
even want to like you don't you don't
want that to be the reason like you know
you use your mom because we've talked
about this before bed it's mild but it's
mad she knows what's happening right now
right she understands
yeah but she's it's like Groundhog Day
is like she's learning it every day yeah
you know yeah it is I mean I was talking
with somebody else about this twos like
I'm not sure what's worse if you have
this sort of Alzheimer's dementia where
you don't recognize anyone or you think
you're 11 years old or all these
different weird things or what I'm
dealing with where you think this person
is okay until they say something that
you go what you know like yeah what are
you talking about you know so it's kind
of like that for me and it could be it
could be difficult like I've you know
I've had moments where I just really hit
me hard but you know like right now
again I want to just go see my parents
and then they're so stubborn it's like
do you want to go to the store and they
want to do things and it's like yeah
keep your ass at home what are you doing
for sure are you parents at your parents
or your parents are pretty good
they're good now I think like
everybody's like you didn't know how
real it was at first right
like I remember I went to I was in
Charleston South Carolina where we shoot
the righteous gemstones and make bride
Danny he invited us to a Sturgill
Simpson concert and if you don't know
Sturgill Simpson he's [ __ ] he's
awesome he's like rock sort of country
ask but awesome concert hung out with
service I'm saying after the show big
concert like probably 15,000 people
there and and then literally the next
day like everything hit like they're
canceling or they're pushing the show we
can't shoot anymore must been like March
11th yeah I think it was the 12th don't
mean I was my that was my birthday
that's like why I haven't in my head
about that time yeah and so we were like
oh [ __ ] like oh this is like real maybe
we shouldn't have been at that concert
then it just came out in the news last
week
Sturgill Simpson has kovat and he had it
he got sick the 13th
he was just in Europe playing like Italy
and [ __ ] and he came and then and then
Charleston was one of the first shows
back in the States we hung out with him
afterwards we're drinking with him
hanging out with him and and then he
gets sick yeah it's just and I'm like
you don't realize like you've probably
been in contact with somebody that has
had it you've probably and that's just
the only reason I know that is he's a
famous person there was like a press
release that came out that he has it
like how's he doing now though he's fine
he's I guess he was like three or four
days that it was like bad where he had a
fever and a bad cough and all this and
then and then he felt fine but couldn't
get a test the doctor said like he can't
get a test and then like he finally got
a test he went through one of those
drive-through tests and then it said
that he is he tested positive for Koba
like he still has a song yeah it's just
so yeah it was real for me when I was I
was in I was in Tennessee doin shows and
like a couple of my other comic buddies
call me up like yo man I can't sell my
shows I'm flying home you know and all
oh [ __ ] what yeah I don't mean you know
and then but I think the real moment for
all of us is when Tom Hanks you know oh
dude I said that from the jump I'm like
I don't believe in conspiracy theories
like 99% of the time I think you know
there's a rational explanation yes
people aren't really evil like no one's
really like out to get anyone else for
the most part like sure Hitler existed
but for the most part people are
inherently decent people right and or at
least you see the reason that they're
doing and they're doing the things that
they're doing yeah you know but but when
Tom Hanks was the first celebrity I
heard that got it I'm like oh
something's up
what how is the most famous most beloved
person in the world the one person to
get coronavirus I know it couldn't it
couldn't have been the sixth lead off of
suits no no it would've been huge Adam
Devine has corona that would be like I
think it'll been more that like I think
we were scared for Tom Hanks because we
know he's not a young man and and I was
waiting to hear I thought to myself they
were already at that point buying up all
the toilet paper and acting crazy and I
thought if Tom Hanks dies of a corona
it's gonna be Armageddon yeah I know I
mean so to know that he recovered and
they're fine he's hosting SNL it makes
you it maybe kind of feel like okay
there's another side to this yeah you
know people are dying and then there's
pre-existing conditions there's like
there's so much signs to that I don't
even understand like I saw this great
poster words said how can something that
soap and hand sanitizer can kill that we
don't have the cure for yet
you know absolutely but just a common
sense science of that makes sense to me
but like I'm sure there's more there's
more sciency [ __ ] to the reasons why
that's not accurate but you know yeah it
became real you know I think the Tom
Hanks was the first real moment I think
we're on edge waiting to find out give
us some Tom Hanks news yeah for sure
when I heard that it was like oh like
he's the first person that you heard of
that got it and he's also like an
American's dad you know you grew up with
it now like everybody there's not a
[ __ ] human being that doesn't like
Tom Hanks yeah so for him to get it I
was like oh boy he's in the top 20 I
would say most famous people on the
planet wouldn't you say top 10 like he's
so famous and also not even just famous
like sure Brad Pitt's famous but Brad
Pitt seems untouchable like you don't
think like Brad Pitt it doesn't seem
like a real person he's so like handsome
and wealthy and it's just like he has
got an air of like regality to him one
like but like Tom Hanks is like oh I
feel like I know that guy yeah yeah only
thing I think Brad Pitt would get is
like herpes maybe but it lost his sense
of taste in Smith it's the last thing I
want to ask you about is like what are
you watching right now like what are you
catching up on you work so much you
[ __ ] work so much it ruined our
Clippers seasons that you know we you
know what I'm saying
are you working but you know what I mean
like are you uh like what are you
watching are you taking time till I
catch up on things you never got to
watch we're watching so much [ __ ] oh I
watched all of the Harry Potter movies
and never said that
for Microsoft's outraged never watch him
and Chloe who was like huge Harry Potter
fan so she like if he wanted to watch
them all and I was like alright fine
I'll watch them to be to be a nice coin
team spouse and you a Hufflepuff are you
what are you a Gryffindor what are you
know yeah watch Harry Potter and now
we're watching we're like through season
five of the Americans and if you haven't
seen that show go back and watch it it's
oh oh that's one of those lights you
know that's one of those that you hear
everybody talking about it's critically
acclaimed but I just couldn't get into
another TV relationship I had too many
as it is but you know what you're right
I got to put that on the list America
it's really really good and it's it's
the perfect one to like watch through
quarantine because it's not so it's not
like The Sopranos or the wire or
something that like everybody talked
about it and it wanted all the awards so
like right so you didn't end up watching
it this is like it was like a tear below
that so you kind of went under radar for
at least for me and then and then I
watched on like oh this is an awesome
show
so yeah watching that and you know
obviously watched Tiger King imagine you
like workaholics oh yeah exactly I was a
fan for sure
cool hi Chloe I gotta get you on the
podcast to the podcast
she says she's good yeah watch tiger
King I'm watching just how much his
Netflix show called money heist it's
like Spanish
oh it's so good and it is like five tips
four seasons of it on there so it's
perfect to like because I can't stand
when stuff like especially right now I
don't want to start something that you
there's a cliffhanger and I'm like oh
[ __ ] we're not gonna get this for five
years like Westworld is like back on and
I'm like I don't really care cuz I'm
like you're made it you're making me
wait a whole week yeah what I'm in
quarantine the employer watching like
seven episodes of American tonight I put
on Entourage the other day entourage oh
wow you're really struggling yeah and
like just had it on for the day and win
about my [ __ ] you came in and be like oh
turtle once again I've been watching
this I've been watching this Maria Conda
tidying up on Netflix
Rachel's making me watch that just to be
like t-shirts and tiny little squares
for a minute
yeah it's good a little like you know I
need her to come take care of my Netflix
like I need her to tidy up you know what
I mean it's such a nightmare dude you
watching any documentaries and you into
that kind of stuff watching anything
right now I feel like I've watched all
the good documentaries on Netflix
did you see how to stop how to how to
stop a drug scandal and then like Bobby
Lee had me watched this one called dear
Zachary it's on Amazon Prime
it is so man so heart-wrenching and it's
a really great documentary it's got a
murder mystery in it so check those out
well all right man all right mr.
Gryffindor I think we passed complete no
honestly I really appreciate it you know
you seriously are one of my favorite
people in the world always I just want
to say I do appreciate all the times
we've had together
you know from workaholics on because
workaholics literally changed my life
and I know that you guys were a main
part of me
getting apart season one you know I know
it was like cuz I know it was like I had
to do like five auditions it was crazy
it was like every single time it was
like a different note it was like you're
too big then it was like what you do it
so I know that was like this big process
and you guys were like young and you had
to like do whatever they said and you
you guys did your thing and I appreciate
you and I congratulate you on being
engaged Chloe is a magnificent woman she
rolls yeah she rules you thanks man and
we gotta go to some more games again I'm
not on 75 shows at the same time with as
you animated movies and all this kind of
stuff do you know this is you know
daddy's still working hard to like make
ends meet get three again like you know
so be doing Chloe your uncle your mascot
that goes I don't go anyplace without
Montez it's good talk abou talk soon all
right I appreciate you all right take
care
peace